[Musik]
und jetzt das heute schon mal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta Slomka guten Abend
sollte es in Moskau Befürchtungen
gegeben haben dass die NATO ihre Tore
für die Ukraine öffnet so kann man sich
im cremel jetzt halbwegs beruhigt
zurücklehnen das ist nicht geschehen um
ein weiteres jetzt noch während des
Krieges ging es ja eh nicht gestritten
wurde nur darüber wie konkret man der
Ukraine eine Perspektive für die Zeit
danach gibt eine förmliche Einladung
etwa darauf hatte Kiew gehofft eine
Mehrheit der NATO-Mitglieder wäre für
ein solch deutliches Zeichen gewesen
aber einige Staaten angeführt von den
USA und Deutschland waren dagegen und so
endete dieser erste Gipfeltag früher als
erwartet und mit einem Kompromiss ohne
zusagen
es geht bei diesen Treffen auch um Größe
Symbolik bedeutet viel in der Gipfel
Hierarchie eine Regierungsmaschine sie
irritiert ein Totenkopf ziert sie wer
fährt sofort mehr später dazu denn
beginnen wollen wir mit dem Sieger des
Gipfels Schwedens regierungs-
[Applaus]
wir suchen Schutz durch das Bündnis aber
alle sollten auch wissen dass auch wir
das Bündnis sicherer machen werden
und wann steht die Ukraine mit auf dem
Familienfoto der NATO bald sagen alle
aber was heißt bald für die Osteuropäer
direkt nach dem Kriegsende unter anderem
die USA und Deutschland sind da
vorsichtiger sprechen von Bedingungen
die die Ukraine vor dem Beitritt
erfüllen muss der Nato-Generalsekretär
vermeidet zu Beginn des Gipfels deshalb
konkrete Zusagen
unsere Botschaft wird positiv stark und
einig sein und nicht konkret und damit
stößt sie dem ukrainischen Präsidenten
bitter auf ganz uniplomatisch machte auf
Twitter seinem Unmut Luft es ist
beispiellos und absurd dass es weder
einen Zeitraum für eine Einladung noch
eine Zusage für eine NATO-Mitgliedschaft
der Ukraine gibt der Gipfel hat einen
Streit das wollte die NATO eigentlich
vermeiden gerade beim Thema Ukraine will
das Bündnis Geschlossenheit zeigen die
Außenministerin versucht die Wogen zu
glätten zeigt Verständnis für die Wut
von selensky
das all das was wir hier gemeinsam
beschließen ein weiterer militärischer
Unterstützung an weiterer Zusammenarbeit
an Vertiefung dass das für ein Land was
in einem brutalen Angriffskrieg ist
alles zusammen nicht genug sein kann der
Bundeskanzler kommt wie immer mit
Aktentasche und bringt ein
Versöhnungsgeschenk für die Ukraine mit
ein militärpaket im Wert von 700
Millionen Euro
jetzt geht es darum dass wir die Ukraine
aktiv unterstützen bei der Verteidigung
ihrer Souveränität und Integrität auch
mit den Waffenlieferung die all die
Staaten jeweils mobilisieren zielenski
ist in Vilnius angekommen und lässt sich
von der litauischen Bevölkerung feiern
es ist ein emotionaler Auftritt ein
Auftritt an die NATO gerichtet
die Ukraine wird die NATO stärker machen
aber die hat keinen Zeitplan für einen
Beitritt beschlossen und damit auch
keine Einladung ausgesprochen
Stoltenberg versucht dies dennoch der
Ukraine positiv zu verkaufen
wir haben etwas entscheidend verändert
es ist jetzt nur noch ein Schritt und
nicht mehr zwei Schritte für die Ukraine
zur Mitgliedschaft immer noch einen
Schritt zu viel für selensky es wird
wohl noch dauern bis die Ukraine zur
NATO gehört ach ja da war ja noch was
aus dem regierungsflieger mit dem
Totenkopf stieg die Delegation von
Luxemburg aus sie hatte ihn für den
Gipfel von einer Rockband gemietet
ja wie ist dieses nato-ergebnis
einzuordnen darüber wollen wir mit dem
Politikwissenschaftler nikolange
sprechen er hat unter der vorherigen
Bundesregierung den leitungsstab im
Bundesverteidigungsministerium geführt
guten Abend Herr Lange
guten Abend sie sind da gerade bei einer
zeitenwendeveranstaltung der Münchner
Sicherheitskonferenz in Saarland
Zeitenwende ist jetzt weil
wahrscheinlich eher nicht der Begriff
den sie für das Ergebnis des heutigen
NATO-Gipfels verwenden würden oder
es ist keine Zeitenwende in Bezug auf
die Perspektive für die Ukraine die
Ukraine hat gehofft dass die abstrakte
Perspektive aus Bukarest von 2008 jetzt
zu einer konkreten Perspektive wird und
das ist leider nicht passiert das ist
eine Politik der offenen Tür aber nicht
das was die Ukraine sich erhofft hat was
hat denn ihre Einschätzung nach den
Ausschlag gegeben das hat ja nicht nur
die Ukraine gehofft sondern es gab ja
auch eine Mehrheit sogar der
nato-mitgliedsländer die konkreter
werden wollten warum war das am Ende
nicht möglich
in der NATO muss im Konsens entschieden
werden es gab eine Gruppe von Staaten
die keine konkreteren Formulierungen
wollte in diesem Papier für die Ukraine
ist das besonders bedauerlich weil sie
glaube ich Verbündete hat in der NATO
die wissen es geht nicht um Worte es
geht nicht um Beschlüsse und Papier
sondern es geht um den Existenzkampf der
Ukraine und da ist diese
nato-perspektive einfach die einzige
Garantie für Sicherheit die man kennt
die funktioniert und die die Ukraine aus
ihrer Sicht braucht und auch Partner in
Mittel Osteuropa brauchen diese
Perspektive für die Ukraine weil sie
glauben dass das für Ihre Sicherheit ein
ganz entscheidender Schritt wäre dann
hatte der US-Präsident ja im Vorfeld
dieses Gipfels in einem Interview von
einem Modell Israel gesprochen also
besonderen Schutz zu sagen der USA für
die Ukraine ähnlich über Israel hat sich
daraus jetzt noch irgendetwas ergeben
das ist heute nicht weiter besprochen
worden aber natürlich weiß man dass
Modell Israel in der Ukraine wird
manchmal vom Modell Stachelschwein
gesprochen also eine Ukraine die sich
selbst mit eigenen Mitteln verteidigen
kann das beinhaltet natürlich im Falle
Israels Atomwaffen und auch die Ukraine
wird über alle Möglichkeiten nachdenken
müssen der ukrainische Präsident hat ein
starkes Mandat für von seinen Bürgern
für die Sicherheit der Ukraine zu sorgen
und wenn die NATO sich da nicht zu
konkreten Dingen durchringen kann dann
hat er ja den Auftrag alle Möglichkeiten
zu durchdenken um irgendwie eine sichere
Nachkriegsordnung für die Ukraine
aufbauen zu können dann bedeuten sie
anders die Ukraine darüber nachdenken
könnte sich quasi selbst Atomwaffen zu
besorgen das würde sie aber natürlich
international gewaltig in die bringen
oder
die Ukraine ist in einem Überlebenskampf
und wird alle Überlegungen anstellen die
dafür notwendig sind und wir tun leider
manchmal so als wäre die
NATO-Mitgliedschaft für die Ukraine ein
Almosen oder eine Gefälligkeit die wir
geben und ich glaube das Präsident
selensky zu Recht darauf hinweist dass
es ja um ganz grundlegende grundlegende
Fragen der sicherheitsordnung in Europa
geht er wird jedenfalls weiter daran
arbeiten er hat eine sehr bewegende Rede
gehalten heute Abend in Vilnius wir
können vielleicht noch ein bisschen
darauf hoffen was denn die erste Sitzung
des NATO Ukraine Rates Morgen bringt
vielleicht gibt es da mehr Verständnis
für einen Prozess der am Ende zu einer
konkreteren Perspektive für die Ukraine
führen könnte
Nico lange danke für die Analyse
nicht nur die Ukraine hatte sich mehr
erhofft unterstützt wurde sie darin vor
allem von Staaten die zum ehemaligen
Ostblock gehörten und ihre ganz eigenen
Erfahrungen mit der Sowjetunion bzw
Russland gemacht haben mit Ausnahme
Ungarns waren vor allem diese Länder von
Kriegsbeginn an für Waffenlieferungen
und drängten auch schon frühzeitig auf
eine raschere nato-perspektive für die
Ukraine zu dieser Gruppe gehört die
Tschechische Republik mit ihrem
Außenminister habe ich darüber am
Nachmittag gesprochen als in den
Verhandlungen noch einiges an Bewegung
war vor diesem Interview blicken wir bei
erst noch in die Ukraine dort hat daran
Hasan sadi heute Stimmen in Kiel für
eingefangen
auch heute gibt es Luftalarm in Kiew
seit Kriegsbeginn schon fast Normalität
der NATO-Gipfel in Litauen ist noch hier
Thema die Menschen gerade die jungen
wollen dazu gehören zur Europäischen
Union und zur NATO
ich denke solange Krieg herrscht werden
wir nicht akzeptiert
vielleicht nach unserem Sieg können wir
ein Mitglied der NATO werden
wichtiger Verhandlungen stattfinden an
denen unser Präsident teilnimmt
dann wird die Ukraine immer besonders
stark angegriffen
Provokationen Luftangriffe auf uns
werden intensiviert das macht krank
[Musik]
ich weiß dass es ein schwieriger
bürokratischer Prozess ist und es ist
ein Prozess der eher langfristig
angelegt ist als kurzfristig enden wird
in einem Außenbezirk von Kiew treffen
wir Pfarrer Anatoli seit Kriegsbeginn
ist er mehr Logistiker für Hilfsgüter
denn Seelsorger
ich sehe die Fakten die EU hat Angst vor
Russland das war der Grund warum wir
unsere Chance auf die
NATO-Mitgliedschaft vor 15 Jahren
verloren haben und die heutige
Entscheidung so fürchte ich wird wieder
ausweichend sein
Einzelstimmen wie das ukrainische Volk
in seiner Gesamtheit denkt weiß Anton
koschitzki er leitet das Kiefer Institut
für Soziologie es erforscht die
politischen Einstellungen der Ukraine
seit 30 Jahren
vor dem russischen Angriffskrieg
sprachen sich nur 50% der Ukraine für
einen NATO-Beitritt aus und die Mehrheit
im Süden und Osten im Land war sogar
dagegen aber jetzt nach Beginn des
Angriffskrieges wollen fast 90% der
Ukraine in die nato-familie und mit
einer Mehrheit von über 80% in allen
Landesteilen
in der Ukraine hat man so sehr auf ein
klares Zeichen von NATO-Gipfel gehofft
jetzt wissen sie dass sie noch lange
nicht dazugehören werden die
Enttäuschung darüber wird groß sein
und über die Perspektiven der Ukraine
auf diesen Gipfel wollen wir mit dem
Außenminister der Tschechischen Republik
sprechen mit lang Jan lipowski guten
Abend gute Nacht gehen
danke dass ich bei Ihnen sein kann
Tschechien gehört zu den starken
Unterstützern der Ukraine sie sprechen
sich auch für einen möglichst raschen
Beitritt der Ukraine nach einem
Waffenstillstand oder einem
Friedensvertrag aus haben Sie keine
Sorge dass das zu einer zusätzlichen
Eskalation mit Russland führen könnte
ST du die total
opposite ich glaube das führt zum
Gegenteil und die NATO werden zum
schluss endlich Sicherheit nach
Osteuropa bringen russland hat auf
verschiedene Art und Weise Osteuropa
destabilisiert Jahrzehnte lang
hat nie abgelassen von seinem
imperialistischen Traum Territorien
außerhalb der russischen Grenzen zu
beherrschen und die Ukraine in der NATO
ist eine großartige Möglichkeit für die
Osteuropa eine Lösung zu finden so dass
die Ukraine bitte in den Grenzen von
1994 steht
und Russland hat ja gegen das
angriffskriegsverbot der UN verboten und
das wird dann auch richtig es geht bei
der Ukraine darum Frieden nach Europa zu
bringen
die NATO Mitglieder bislang nicht einig
wie es weiter vorangehen soll sie sind
sich aber zumindestens alle einig dass
eine richtige Mitgliedschaft der Ukraine
erst nach einem Jahr Friedensvertrag
oder Waffenstillstand in Frage kommen
ist das nicht ein Anreiz für Russland
diesen Krieg ewig am Kochen zu halten
damit genau das nicht eintritt diese an
Mitgliedschaft der Ukraine in der NATO
weniger deswegen müssen
unterstützen in ihrem Kampf gegen den
russischen Aggressoren und das ist ja
auch der Grund warum wir weitermachen
die tierischen politischen
wirtschaftlichen und militärischen Hilfe
für die Ukraine um die Ukraine zu
verteidigen
das ist ja ein Krieg den sich die
Ukraine nicht ausgesucht hat und wenn
das erstmal vorbei ist kann die Ukraine
ein Betrieb der NATO werden warten wir
einfach mal darauf was in kommunalität
morgen am Ende des Gipfels steht wir
sprechen jetzt am Nachmittag im
Präsident zielensky ist gerade in
Vilnius eingetroffen er hat ja hohe
Erwartungen er will wenigstens eine
formale Einladung zu einem Beitritt
haben und es insbesondere die deutsche
Regierung bislang jedenfalls dagegen und
sagt nee also eine Einladung solange
noch Krieg ist das machen wir nicht mit
sind sie denn zuversichtlich dass es
überhaupt zu einem gemeinsamen Linie
unter den NATO Mitgliedern kommen wird
es ist jetzt einfach noch zu früh die
Situation zu bewerten aber ich glaube
jeder stimmt über einen auch die
Ukrainer dass die Ukraine nach dem Krieg
beitreten wird
dieses nach dem Krieg ist ja ein Datum
von dem wir alle nicht wissen wann es
Eintritt deshalb gibt's auch in
Deutschland zum Stimmen die sagen man
sollte jetzt möglichst schnell auf einen
Waffenstillstand vielleicht auch von
einfrierendes Konflikt hin aber damit
nicht noch mehr Menschen in diesem Krieg
sterben damit es nicht noch mehr
eskaliert und womöglich Putin
irgendetwas völlig irrationales tut
diese Befürchtung haben sie nicht dass
er das tun könnte ich fragte sie das
eingangs schon mal
genau Russia will be presenting
Russland jetzt über Jahrzehnte eine
Bedrohung für Europa sein auch wenn es
Putin nicht mehr gibt da gibt es den
russischen im Realismus und danach wird
Russland so seltsam reagieren und
entsprechende Maßnahmen treffen das ist
die ostfranke der NATO und deswegen
müssen wir helfen dass die Ukraine
gewinnt und das so Russland sich an die
Prinzipien der un-kater hält und
Russland hat ja Territorien der Ukraine
annektiert und das muss wieder
rückgängig gemacht werden das ist nicht
akzeptabel und das sind Prinzipien die
es die
verbündet wurden verletzt wurden über
Jahrhunderte zur Blutvergießen in Europa
führten es geht hier um ein
wirtschaftlicher Friedensprojekt und wir
müssen aufbauen auf diese Werte die der
arbeitet haben mein Tschechien ist ein
unabhängiges Land und wir haben eine
halbe Million Kriegsflüchtlinge aus der
Ukraine akzeptiert und wir haben einen
großen Zustrom gehabt und wir hatten
einen schweren Winter die Energiepreise
sind durch die Decke geschossen bei
Putin sich entschlossen hat die
Energiekrise in Europa zu befördern und
wir müssen einfach finden wie wir diese
Sicherheitsfragen in Europa endlich
lösen können und wir können das nur
dadurch dass wir die Ukraine jetzt schon
versetzen seine Demokratie und
Souveränität zu verteidigen und gute
Prinzipien und Werte zu
durchzusetzen freie demokratische Wahlen
damit hat Putin keine Erfahrung und wir
sollten auch da hinauf darauf
hinarbeiten
Minister der Tschechischen Republik ich
danke sehr für dieses Gespräch danke
gewissermaßen im Schatten der
Weltpolitik gab es bei der CDU heute ein
kleines Erdbeben an das formuliert eine
überraschende Personalentscheidung damit
beginnen wir dir die Nachrichten heißt
der CDU-Chef merzwechselt nach gut
eineinhalb Jahren der Generalsekretär
aus Mario Czaja und März hätten sich
heute einvernehmlich darauf verständigt
ihre Zusammenarbeit an der Parteispitze
zu beenden teilte die CDU mit Nachfolger
soll demnach Carsten Linnemann werden
Bundestagsabgeordneter und Chef der
grundsatzkommission der CDU März werde
morgen dem CDU Präsidium und
Bundesvorstand vorschlagen Linnemann zum
kommissarischen Generalsekretär zu
bestellen
noch eine Meldung zur CDU der wegen
umstrittene Äußerungen in der Kritik
stehende ex-verfassungsschutzpräsident
Maaßen kann nach der Entscheidung eines
Kreispartei Gerichts in Thüringen in der
CDU bleiben die Maßen mitteilte sei das
Parteiausschlussverfahren abgelehnt
worden und die Anordnung ihm seine
Mitgliedsrechte zu entziehen sei
aufgehoben worden
in Deutschland sind im vergangenen Jahr
deutlich mehr Fälle von häuslicher
Gewalt gemeldet worden als im Jahr zuvor
das zeigt das aktuelle Lagebild des
bundeskriminalsamtes vor allem die
Zahlen zu Gewalt in Partnerschaften sind
gestiegen 2022 wurden hier mehr als
157.000 Fälle gemeldet
432 Taten pro Tag das sind 9,4% mehr als
im Vorjahr 80% der Opfer waren Frauen
das Dunkelfeld ist laut BKA erheblich
die tatsächlichen Zahlen dürften also
weit höher liegen
nach der Bund ländereinigung für eine
krankenhausreform werden Forderungen
nach übergangshilfen lauter der Chef der
Deutschen Krankenhausgesellschaft das
warnte mit Blick auf akute Finanznöte
davor auf positivere Form Effekte in
einigen Jahren zu warten man werde
verlorene Standorte nicht wiederbeleben
können
Ärztevertreter Kommunen Krankenkassen
und Gewerkschaften forderten baldige
Klarheit über die Finanzierung von
Kosten die durch einen Umbau des bunten
bundesweiten kliniknetzes zu erwarten
sind
in Israel treibt die Regierung ihre
umstrittene Justizreform weiter voran
das Parlament stimmte in der Nacht den
erster Lesung dafür die Rechte des
Verfassungsgerichts zu beschränken
erneut protestierten daraufhin 10.000
der landesweit seit heute morgen
blockieren die Demonstranten wichtige
Straßen dutzende Menschen wurden
inzwischen festgenommen Präsident Herzog
nennt das Vorgehen der Regierung einen
Fehler von historischem Ausmaß
die letzte Woche soll die weltweit
heißeste erste Juliwoche seit Beginn der
Wetteraufzeichnungen gewesen sein und
diese Woche geht so weiter in den
südlicheren Ländern Frankreich Spanien
Griechenland steigen die Temperaturen
bereits über 40 Grad für Themen werden
Ende der Woche gar Höchsttemperaturen
von 45 Grad erwartet da sollte man sich
den Gang auf die Akropolis sparen wie
gefährlich solche Temperaturen sind war
schon in der Hitzewelle letzten Sommer
zu sehen mit mehr als 60.000 Hitze Toten
in Europa in Deutschland starben mehr
Menschen an Hitze als durch Unfälle in
Straßenverkehr für Deutschland wird ein
nationaler hitzeschutzplan erst noch
entwickelt einzelne Städte und
Landkreise gehen da aber schon voran mit
der sonnewald Berichte
es ist wieder einer dieser Tage mit
Temperaturen über 30 Grad doch im
niederbayerischen Straubing sind sie
dafür längst gerüstet mit
sprühnebel-anlagen schattenbänken und
einem kostenlosen Trinkwasserbrunnen all
das haben sich die Bürger hier selbst
gewünscht bei einer Umfrage nach
Maßnahmen gegen die Hitze auf alle Fälle
finde ich das Konzept gut dass da jetzt
sich mal was tut auch zum beschatten vom
Stadtplatz finde ich gut sollte jede
Stadt machen man hat zu meiner natürlich
den Umwelt Aspekt mit der Begrünung aber
man wird natürlich auch was für die
Leute und für die Stadt und die Hitze
einfach wegzuhalten genau das ist sein
Ziel Alfred solle der Arzt und zugleich
Bürgermeister von Straubing hat für
seine Stadt einen hitzeschutzplan
entwickelt bisher ist das einzigartig in
Bayern wir haben ja ganz viele große
Plätze bei uns in unserem Land die
einfach Hitze ansaugen und in denen es
einfach heiß ist und da muss einfach
dagegen aber das Schlagwort ist grün für
grau heißt im Klartext wir brauchen
viel Pflanzen wir brauchen Bäume wir
brauchen Beschattungen wir brauchen
einfach eine Umstrukturierung unserer
Umwelt die Auswirkungen der immer heißer
werdenden Sommer spüren Sie auch in den
Notaufnahmen wie hier an der Münchner
Uniklinik bei Hitzewellen leiden
deutlich mehr Menschen unter
Herz-Kreislaufproblemen und
Schlaganfällen auch Lungen und
Nierenerkrankungen können akuter werden
bei hohen Temperaturen zum Beispiel ganz
schwere Krankheitsbilder sind
Hitzeschlag ein schwerer Hitzeschlag
kommt bei älteren Menschen vor aber auch
bei jungen Sportlern der sich übernehmen
Marathonläufer die können schwer also
sehr hohe Temperaturen entwickeln bis
über 40 Grad Körpertemperatur sein
akuter Notfall Deutschland sei schlecht
auf solche Hitzewellen vorbereitet so
Martin Hermann seit Jahren beschäftigt
sich der gelernte Arzt mit den
Auswirkungen des Klimawandels auf die
Gesundheit er fordert eine Energiewende
auch um einen gesundheitlichen Kollaps
abzuwenden es kann zu Situationen kommen
mit denen wir nicht mehr umgehen können
weil über längere Zeit ein Hitze Szen
Radio da ist wo ganz viele Menschen
versterben wo wir also eine
hitzekatastrophe haben die über weiten
Teilen Deutschlands hängen kann deswegen
ist es extrem wichtig dass wir
Klimaschutz ernst nehmen und so schnell
wie möglich aus den fossilen Energien
rauskommen Bürgermeister solle da setzt
mit seinem Pilotprojekt gegen Hitze
bereits Maßstäbe als nächstes will er in
Straubing Klinik Hausärzte Apotheken und
Seniorenheime miteinander vernetzen als
Frühwarnsystem wenn die Temperaturen
hier wieder über 30 Grad steigen
und mit Extremwetter geht jetzt auch bei
dir noch mal weiter ja es gibt aktuelle
Unwetterwarnungen des Deutschen
Wetterdienstes gewarnt wird vor schweren
Gewittern mit heftigem Starkregen und
Hagel in Teilen des Saarlandes und von
Rheinland-Pfalz und auch in großen
Teilen Baden-Württembergs wo noch die
Warnung vor Orkanböen hinzukommt in den
vergangenen Stunden sind bereits einige
unwetterfronten über Deutschland
hinweggezogen aus Frankreich zog eine
sogenannte Superzelle heran und erreicht
am Abend Baden-Württemberg sie brachte
Starkregen und Hagel mit sich in Freisen
im Saarland soll sogar ein Tornado
gemütet haben zahlreiche Dächer wurden
abgedeckt und hunderte Bäume entwurzelt
die Feuerwehr aus dem ganzen Landkreis
war im Einsatz
und mehr zur Wetterlage gleichen
Wetterbericht von Katja horneffer
eine der Begleiterscheinungen der
corona-pandemie war ja mehr Homeoffice
Arbeit und nun zeigen neue Zahlen der
Statistischen Bundesamtes das weiterhin
viele zumindest teilweise im Homeoffice
sind weil reale da gibt es natürlich je
nach Branche große Unterschiede genau
ganz deutliche bestimmte Berufsgruppen
können ja kaum im Homeoffice arbeiten
also in der Medizin der Pflege beim
Bauhandwerk Einzelhandel da gibt es so
gut wie keine Möglichkeit von zu Hause
aus zu arbeiten andererseits profitieren
zum Beispiel
IT-Dienstleister und Büro Beschäftigte
von der sozusagen neuen Freiheit am
allermeisten für die die es können und
dürfen ist es zur Normalität geworden
nach der Pandemie ist die Homeoffice
Quote kaum zurückgegangen fast ein
Viertel aller Beschäftigten arbeitete
vergangenes Jahr zumindest tageweise von
zu Hause aus vor Corona waren es nur
rund halb so viele im internationalen
Vergleich liegt Deutschland damit leicht
über dem EU-Schnitt am meisten arbeiten
übrigens die nieder davon zu Hause aus
viele Arbeiter Arbeitnehmer nutzen
Homeoffice also gerne wir gehen die
Arbeitgeber damit um ganz
unterschiedlich die ersten Versuchen
schon ihre Leute zurück ins Büro zu
holen Arbeitgeber machen sich Sorgen um
die Mitarbeiterbindung und Produktivität
und Motivation im Homeoffice auch weiß
man dass Kreativität beispielsweise in
Präsenz besser funktioniert als in einem
Videocall andererseits sparen Konzerne
Bürokosten weil sie zum Teil deutlich
weniger Fläche brauchen also komplexes
Thema das noch nicht ausgehandelt ist
aber viele haben sich als Arbeiten zu
Hause gewöhnt die Zahnpasta kriegt man
nicht zurück in die Tube Maria vielen
Dank
die Inflation ist im Juni wieder stärker
gestiegen die Verbraucherpreise zogen
gegenüber dem Vorjahresmonat um 6,4
Prozent Anteil der Statistische
Bundesamt mit und bestätigte damit
vorläufige Daten stärkster Preistreiber
sein nach wie vor die Nahrungsmittel
zum Sport bei der paralle Leichtathletik
WM in Paris hat Janis Fischer die zweite
Goldmedaille für das deutsche Team
geholt der 21-Jährige Kugelstoßer gewann
mit einer weit von Elfmeter 3 und
stellte bei seinem Debüt gleich noch
einen neuen wm-record auf für Fische ist
es der bislang größte Erfolg seiner
Karriere
Georg Zimmermann hat bei der Tour de
France den ersten deutschen Etappensieg
in diesem Jahr nur knapp verpasst er kam
als Zweiter hinter dem Spanier Bilbao
ins Ziel
der Augsburger liegt kurz vor dem Ziel
in Führung kann dem Antritt von Pelle
Bilbao beim Sprint um den
tagessiegerband nichts mehr
entgegensetzen nach dem ersten Ruhetag
bei der Tour fehlen Zimmermann nach mehr
als 100 Kilometern in der
Ausreißergruppe die nötigen Kräfte der
Spanier Bilbao vom Team bei Rhein
Victorius widmet den Sieg seinem
Mannschaftskameraden Gino Mäder aus der
Schweiz der im Juni bei der Tour des
Swiss nach einem schweren Sturz
gestorben war
auf der nordatlantikinsel Island ist das
dritte Jahr in Folge ein Vulkan nahe der
hauptstadtig ausgebrochen der Vulkan
befindet sich in einem unbewohnten Tal
und die Behörden warnten da vor sich dem
Vulkan zu nähern dort könnten sich hohe
Mengen an giftigen Gasen sammeln nach
der ersten heftigen Eruption tritt aus
seiner etwa 900 Meter langen Erdspalte
Lava aus der Ausbruch hatte sich durch
teils heftige Erdbeben angekündigt
das war von uns vielleicht nach dem
Wetter geht satirisch weiter mit der
Anstalt und gegen 0 20 meldet sich dann
gökte mir mit unserem heutigen Update
morgen auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend vor der Kaltfront eines
Tiefs über den Nordsee haben sich heute
hier über Frankreich kräftige Gewitter
entwickelt die höchsten Wolken habe ich
für Sie mal rot eingefärbt daran
erkennen sie nämlich sehr schön wie
dieser gewitterkomplex über das Saarland
Rheinland-Pfalz und Baden-Württemberg
weiter in Richtung Nordosten gezogen ist
wir sprechen von sehr sehr kräftigen
Gewittern die sich auch im Laufe der
Nacht weiter nach Osten aus denen werden
erst am frühen Morgen verlassen sie
Deutschland dann hier ostwärts
Regenschauer und Gewitter gibt es auch
im Nordwesten die fallen aber nicht zu
heftig aus in den Alpen gab es bereits
Orkanböen und auch jetzt müssen wir hier
im alten Fulda mit Orkanböen rechnen es
sind wohl auch schon Bäume umgestürzt
die hagelkorngrößen werden so 2 bis 5 cm
sein 7 cm wurden schon berichtet und es
kann auch sehr heftig regnen 40 Liter
Regen pro Quadratmeter
nebenbei ist das auch noch eine häufig
tropische Nacht in der die Temperaturen
nicht unter 20 Grad senken morgen ist es
dann deutlich angenehmer bei den
Temperaturen dann liegen die zwischen 20
und 30 Grad es gibt morgen noch einige
Gewitter hier in Vorpommern dann kommen
neue Regenschauer von der Nordseeküste
heran und auch im südlichen Brandenburg
sind Schauer und Gewitter nicht ganz
ausgeschlossen nachmittags aber brodelt
es wieder im alten Vorland da gibt es
wieder kräftige Unwetter Schauer und
Gewitter danach beruhigt sich die Lage
deutlich jedenfalls vorübergehend zum
Freitag guten Abend